Tech cast now topic for today is next
week waves of cloud computing and trends
for the future
now guys just make sure you give me a
confirmation on the chat box where on
which whether you can hear me or not as
I'm loud and clear to you let me just
type it on the chat box for you and I
are the booth you can go ahead and reply
yes or no I mean why let me just go
ahead and check the audio and with suti
that's hey Sujit welcome to the tech
cast and thank you so much for joining
are you that you hear me can you just
give me a confirmation on that yeah
either way I'm able to hear you properly
- clear thank thank you thanks a lot
thanks a lot so guys today you know we
all know that cloud computing is being
used extensively by many organizations
and businesses right we all know that
right from the US Army to the local
restaurants everybody is trying to use
it you know to lower your cost and also
to improve the business efficiency you
know so inside that actually bring so
many questions in my mind and one of
them is that what does it actually mean
for you know IT professionals expiring
to build a career in this domain and to
you know and this is a very big question
right you know which have so many
different factors associated with it you
know so no and for that you know we have
sujeet and also did Saxena with us who
is an expert in cloud computing a friend
of mine and as well as the chief manager
of IT at Siemens
right so he's a great personality a
great person at heart and a good friend
of mine so so you - you know basically I
get so many questions like this you know
that how is cloud computing impacting
the business today as well as the people
who have you know a lot of you know
ideas
lot of you know goals which they want to
you know get in IT field and how can
cloud computing you know you know can
help them in do that so without no
further ado guys let me just go ahead
and you know us the men of the are
sujeet 16 are to go ahead and not share
his knowledge so that you can benefit
out of it so sujeet the you know you can
please take it away from you and i'll be
more than happy to you know guys i would
really appreciate if you can note down
the know you know know down the points
actually saying because it's going to be
really important through you know build
your career in cloud computing so over
to usage it thanks relief thanks for the
nice introduction in nice lines about
myself and i share really your concern
what about you mentioned about the cloud
computing there are a lot of questions
which many of newcomers even the
experienced professionals think about
that and they think they try to think
about what what is it that cloud
computing is what is the hype about and
how is it really affecting the
organizations how it developed and what
are the future trends and basically what
is in it for me so that is something
which normally a person connected with
IT thinks of so what i am now sharing is
starting to share my first slide which
is there i hope you are all able to see
that
confirm that you are able to see this
right
/ yes indeed I can see digital economy
okay right great thanks so good morning
good afternoon and good evening to the
all the persons who have joined and
thanks for joining this webinar I'll be
sharing my view and also use which I
have collected from different forums and
different technical technological
experts from the internet and based on
my experience the digital economy
the title is digital economy why because
primarily we are all moving and moving
at a rapid pace towards the digital
economy and I will be giving viewing my
presentation bits and pieces of the
information how at what pace we are
moving and I chose this picture because
this picture really gives an idea how a
kind of cloud is affecting all kinds of
communication channels and interfacing
channels which we have today so it just
starts from mail to computers to
networks to globalization digitization
mobile everywhere if you are somewhere
in the background connected with the
cloud and if I take an example in a very
simple way most of us would be using
some kind of email public image Gmail or
hotmail or Outlook or whatever so this
is a very simple example of the cloud
service which is now there
moving to the next this is the agenda
which we will be talking to I will be
talking about so how is cloud computing
beginning development and present state
what are the pros and cons in a very
broad term not go into much details of
that what are the possible job roles in
cloud computing and what are the future
trends so this is the broad agenda which
I will be taking up
like I said in the first slide I'll be
giving you bits and pieces of the data
how we are moving towards the digital
economy so just example a few numbers
you see here so we have 120 hours of
videos are uploaded to YouTube every
minute every day and there are more than
200 million email are exchanged every
minute and the last one is really
surprising and gives you the rapid Ness
of the digital variation which is going
on a server gets activated every 10
seconds to support new smartphones so
this is something which gives you an
idea a mind-boggling idea about this how
things are moving at a fast pace and
this is increasing every day
so definition so the first use of the
terms cloud computing was there
somewhere in August 9 2006 and it was by
by Google CEO Eric Schmidt within broad
introduction that this is a data service
which is provided by servers somewhere
in the cloud and this is they call it as
a cloud computing and university of
california berkley defines cloud
computing as providing the illusion of
infinite computing resources to
end-users on demand and this means
eliminating the upfront investment so
there is no friend investment and if the
services are available to the users and
going forward we will see also how an
ISP is defining these terms in different
categories
this is a bit of data overloaded slide
but what it primarily gives you a
timeline with the events which have
happened not sure if it is visible to
the text to all but the first one is
normally the mainframe which is starting
around somewhere around 1950 and this is
kind of basis for the overall computing
environment and also in a way for the
cloud computing then the next one is in
around 1969 with opponent coming in and
forming the basis for internet at around
the same time
one year later 1970 the IBM released and
was called vm so this is multiple
virtual machines on time sharing so you
see everything the concepts are coming
in and the concepts are already really
they're building in then the PCs came in
which formed the real basis again for
reaching everything to the individual at
a level the next step was
telecommunication companies starting
VPNs which again formed help cloud
computing basis with the segregation of
networks possibly in 1990 sometime then
in 1996 this is the cloud computing term
coined by Ramnath Xalapa and Compaq used
the term in more details with the modern
modern context in 1996 but unfortunately
they could not really get around cash
cash it Ron
next was salesforce.com they started
delivering applications over the web in
around 1999 and then finally amazin came
with their Amazon Web Services in 2002
so which from 1999 onwards the new era
of the cloud computing is started the
next one is
2006 there we have plastic cloud
computing cloud from amazin which again
from Amazon and they allowed small
companies it allows small companies to
get computing infrastructure out of the
Internet itself and then Google
Microsoft and other players came in with
their own apps in 2009 so the you see
this is all coming on in a very gradual
development and all the technological
things which evolved over a period of
time have contributed to the development
of the cloud computing
okay now what is it look like today if
you see just google and turn cloud
computing you see these kind of ads
which is there and which is like amazing
saying 40 plus products 12 months dollar
zero cost you sign up for a free AWS
account today so and all kind of
certification compliant also so HIV so
that's kind of healthcare industry
compliant which is already there you
have secure document sharing
similarly IBM is also opening and there
will be so many ads coming in so the
idea to share this slide is that how it
has become a kind of utility computing
which was the original idea from the
opponent person that some days this
computing will be kind of utility
computing and everybody like electricity
would be able to use it
okay now coming to the foundational
elements what are the basic foundational
elements so this is more or less a
compilation of some of the elements
which we have seen earlier in the in my
earlier slide there we see how it
evolved so but the basic elements on the
modern cloud system which is making it
possible is Virtual Private Network like
I said about segregating the network so
you can really have each customer with
the woman with its own pipeline going to
the cloud Internet bandwidth so Internet
bandwidth increase of engine bandwidth
over a period of time to each individual
consumer and organizations has any paved
way for the possibility of really
getting it to the each user
then there is increase of computing
power so each individual computers
really possible to get so much power
with mainframe of the yesteryears cannot
imagine and even the data centers of the
cloud providers are carrying so much
power that they are able to serve
thousands and millions of customers
every day grid computing is in very
excellent example because this really
gave an idea about how you can connect
different computers and really get the
compute done out of network of the
computers so this was kind of combining
different computers computing power and
getting the result out of that
virtualization we saw VM which was
created by IBM earlier on a time-sharing
basis but this is virtualization of the
virtual machines creation which was done
service-oriented architecture so
targeting all the architecture into a
kind of service mode instead of a
product mode so everything is available
to you as a service like for example
even for a plane nowadays if you want to
if a company goes to buy a plane order
then they ask about the payment in terms
of the flying hours so not in terms of
buying the planes but in terms of
payment using in terms of flying hours
utility computing I mentioned about that
already so utility computing is there
browser-based applications since was
started that already open source there
are so many things everybody is able to
develop and put it on
basic characteristics of the cloud
computing now this is a definition based
on NIH the National Institute of
Standards and technology's from us and
it defines primarily in five
characteristics for a cloud service it
should be on demand self-service that
means the service is available on
customer demand and it is customizable
by the customer at up to an extent and
we will see that in different models
also available over Internet
so services are delivered over internet
or intranet and when I say Internet then
because there is a model which is
private cloud as well and for that
normally this is under different kind of
VPNs or tunneling networks this is more
or less an intranet
the sources are pulled so all the cloud
providers they are putting all their
resources as a pooled and they are
providing with multiple customers with
logical separation and isolation of the
data and it is quick and easy to scale
up and down so you can really the
customer can really ask demand for
scaling up or scaling down depending on
their business requirements and how they
want to see it in the development so
over a period of time they can do that
service metering it is possible for a
cloud provider then to measure the
service and also offer a pay per use
kind of model so as soon as the customer
is going or stopping a service they have
not paying for that so it's not that
that you bought a product and then you
have to maintain it till you have it or
you have to sell that but in this case
it is a service like for
service-oriented architectures or
services there you are utilizing the
service and in the time you are
utilizing you're paying for that
now coming to the deployment models of
the cloud computing so like I said about
a private cloud this refers to a model
of cloud computing where the local IT
provider for the local idea of mentioned
within the company is creating their own
private IT infrastructure for a
dedicated use of the organization and
this is normally managed by internal
resources and this is not accessible to
outside company public is the standard
cloud computing model which is service
provider mix resources available like
virtual machines or applications or
storage and this is available to general
public over the internet and they can
utilize it and this is normally based on
the paper use model some of the
companies like we saw in that there are
some offerings as free also to some
services then there is a community cloud
which is more or less cloud service
model created by organizations for the
purpose of their own and they can create
a joint collaborative model for example
Salesforce they can create a user
community and they can host it on their
own cloud and then all the users are
coming and telling sharing their in
their experiences on that hybrid cloud
is a cloud computing environment which
is a mix of private and public cloud so
when the organization see that they have
they need to secure some things and they
can offer something from the public so
they can distribute it on private and
public and this combination is hybrid so
in the next slide we will see the how
these deployment models are
interconnected so you see there
this organization one which is private
cloud it has its own private cloud then
there is a version 2 version 3 and they
have created together community cloud
which is serving these organizations and
there is a public cloud also from which
organization one is taking services but
this is also accessible to all the
public cloud call the public and with
data isolation of course and hybrid
cloud is depicted in general because it
has both the public and private cloud so
this is how they are kind of
interconnected
cloud service models so there are these
three service models i-s that is
infrastructure-as-a-service ass which is
platform-as-a-service
sass which is software that the service
and the target groups are for sass as
end users for pass it is application
developers for is it is infrastructure
and network architects and the kind of
services provided is these service
service networks OS and application
stack service and package software
now this is interesting thing that which
service model and what are the enablers
for that service model which are there
with the examples so infrastructure as a
service has AWS Amazon Web Services as
you go bulk of Google compute engine
that scalar though it is very
interesting example because it provides
internet whole cloud services then the
virtualization server virtualization VPN
connections and data encryption of
making are the enablers which are making
this kind of model service deployment
model possible mas which is metal as a
service is very interesting because this
allows you to have a physical server
configuration also available over cloud
and that's very specific service
available
platform as a service is Salesforce
Google App Engine Roku and this enable
is making this possible is application
desktop virtualization VDI automated
provisioning software as a service is
Evernote is well known obviously 65
Facebook's email and the enablers which
are making this possible is
service-oriented architecture enterprise
service base data distribution services
another interesting thing on the service
models is who is managing which layer in
different service models so
infrastructure-as-a-service the the user
is managing application data middleware
operating system and virtualization so
there is some overlap because of
different kind of accessibility so
managed by cloud provider they are
managing servers networking storage
voice and virtualization
platform as a service is application and
data managed by a and rest server OS
virtualization middleware etc managed by
cloud provider
software-as-a-service it is only data
which is managed by user rest all
aspects are normally managed from the
cloud provider
now some facts some figures which are
there so if you look closely these are
the cloud initiatives which were
surveyed from RightScale they put a
report together in 2017 and there are
some interesting things which see like
implementing a cloud first strategy
so there are 40% respondent which are
going for cloud first so that means they
are not going to put anything on
investment they will straightaway move
to whatever request or demand business
is there to the cloud first then
expanding use of containers and that's
also very interesting because containers
are really emerging technologies and
this we will talk about this in in a in
few slides later
and enabling IT to broker multiple cloud
services so this is also one of the
interesting things because if you
already have different cloud services
then how to handle them and how to
interface them this is one of the big
challenge and if you see the last one
expanding private cloud and that's
having the least priority because nobody
is really interested now to expand their
own private cloud realizing that this is
only going to give more investment and
more manageability cause
then we come to the next slide on what
is the enterprise referring for and the
preferences for multi-cloud and the
reason is very simple that nobody really
wants to be locked with one provider so
there has to be different kind of
services with different kind of
expertise expert provider available so
if you are going to a different provider
then there is a different expertise
which is available and you can directly
go to that provider
now how private cloud adoption has
happened in from 2016 to 2017 and you
will see here also the trend that
private cloud adoption has either
marginally decreased or not changed at
all
so only in very few cases this has
increased so this is giving an
indication that organizations and
companies they are really looking at for
moving or not increasing their private
cloud adoptions
public cloud adoptions this is giving an
idea at what rate this already the
companies are running the public clouds
and like for you see amazing web
services succeed percent are already on
the running app and even 7% are already
planning to use and these three amazin
ensure that is Microsoft and Google they
are the major players in the market for
the public cloud adoptions there is
however emerging once also coming up
like Alibaba
they are also kind of starting up to
gain
you
then we have a look at enterprise public
cloud adoption and this you see this is
quite different from the private cloud
one so we see this is public cloud is
everybody's increasing towards that
semen from amazing abduction from 59
percent to 68 percent and usher is 43
from 42 to 58 percent so this is even
the major players they are increasing
the organizations have grown more and
more out for the adoption of the public
cloud
like I said earlier some more figures so
Cisco analysis indicated that aggregate
amount of the data stored in the data
centers would be about 370 exabytes and
while worldwide storage capacity would
reach 600 exabytes and these will be
developed these numbers will be
developed
on an aggregate storage up to 1.1 Zeta
byte and even further the global traffic
in 2019 is expected to hit about two
zettabyte now just to give an idea about
we know we are all learning men about
different kind of bytes so one Zeta byte
is one zero two four exabyte and one
megabyte is one zero two four petabyte
and one petabyte is 1 0 to 4 terabyte so
this is more than 1 billion we are
talking about terabytes
and we will see that about 15% of this
would be residing completely on the
clout I would see that names are data
to the pros of the cloud computing and
as you see the first one is cost so cost
is there and CFO's would from my point
of view CFOs would really love it
because you don't have to invest upfront
you don't have any depreciation you
don't have anything to as a asset or
liability to be shown in the book but
you have all the kind of resources
available which you are looking for so
and this is the kind of operational cost
which is coming and the
company can scale up or down then this
is paper use models so there can be
difference in operational costs in terms
that okay you can decide that company is
paying only for a lump sum maybe a
recorder or every six months and even
paper use can be that you decide with
the say Microsoft or some company that
office 365 license measurement is every
month and whatever is measured every
month that is paid so this is kind of
paper use model which is there or maybe
even activated licenses paid and
deactivated licenses not paid so this is
kind of paper use model and the
flexibility which is there which is
coming in terms of cost scalability you
can have storage you don't need to
really consider the storage part with
the exchange or online connection you
straight away if you are going for an
exchange online connection with
Microsoft normally you get a kink 25
gigabytes of storage already on the
cloud same goes with any kind of storage
infrastructure like onedrive Google
Drive or Dropbox you get the storage
immediately in terms of gigabytes so and
you don't have to really put any kind of
hardware in that you can get virtual
machines created you can get virtual
machines created of different
configurations which are available to
you
collaboration so that is a very
interesting thing because it enables the
collaboration across you just need an
internet connection and of course a
secure internet connection then you can
just go ahead and create or get Google
cloud services or Microsoft cloud
services and your users are already
connected over the cloud and they can
start sharing the documents so in a very
simple example like in the families also
we are sharing the photo albums and
different kind of things this is which
is the idea about the collaboration
which is already there
manageability samanage abilities in
terms of IT team and IT infrastructure
so you only have to manage the cloud
part of it
so basically interfacing with the
supplier how things are moving the
resource calculations
maybe capacity sometimes but nothing on
terms of hardware or putting into
Hardware ordered sorry ordering the
hardware installing it device
independence so there is you can access
the data on most of the available
devices including mobile tablet iPad
computers laptop if it is normally seen
is if you have an app or it is browser
compatible app you can really get the
data available to you
even locations like sapa and everything
they provide the data available on
mobile next is mobility and location
independence so you have that wherever
you are sitting you can get the access
to your data you don't need to really be
physically bound to a place where you
can access the data and that is a huge
advantage for the mobile workforce of
the today
data isolation from the local storage so
the data from you are not storing data
on the local storage so that I really
isolated from all the local problems
which could be there on the machine it
is normally in safe if you are already
directly connected with the cloud
this slide is giving an idea about how
the measurable impact on the business
cloud is putting so there is first one
is average improvement in time to market
so because it takes less time to prepare
the solutions and less time to prepare
the infrastructure then overall time
taken to get things to the market is
less you can quickly access to a network
quickly access to the cloud service
provider and then start taking the time
and putting online marketing so like for
example this one is also a very good
example the whole presentation was
already advertised on the LinkedIn and
this was in no time market
increase in company growth so with the
fast deployments this is feasible to
increase the efficiency and then and in
terms the growth
as a verage reduction in the operational
cost so there is nothing on premise
which you need to maintain no
maintenance on that so there is no
maintenance cost because you are going
for paper use scale up models and there
are less resources to maintain so
overall these kind of regular
maintenance part is getting reduced and
where the company needs to focus in
terms of mark time-to-market company
growth orders process efficiency there
they are able to focus
coming to the cons so I would not say
these are really cons but these are more
or less a concern which while deploying
cloud solution or while running a cloud
cinch in the solution must be considered
taken care so that the cloud adoption or
the running of the cloud service is
really run in a secure in a proper way
and the company gets the whole benefit
of the run in the cloud
so Internet bandwidth for connectivity I
mean if you are planning a cloud then
you need to plant sufficient capacity
for the Internet bandwidth and vendor
lock-in so you really need to read
between the lines for service level
agreements with vendors so that you
don't find really lock then sort of
maybe like for example if you have
stored the data but you don't read the
terms for backup and restore so if your
user is accidentally deleting your files
on a cloud then how do you restore so
those kind of aspects
control and flexibility so really need
this is also depending on how you want
to control and the flexibility on the
terms then interfacing from the two
different cloud providers so if you have
dealing with two different cloud
providers and this is what we saw a
challenge which is there which they want
to really give their IT team in the
right scale survey that how to interface
with two different cloud providers and
getting the services from them
data security that is again coming back
with the SLA and the kind of offerings
some of the bigger providers they are
giving good security but maybe smaller
providers are not really geared up for
that and that really need to be looked
into and then what kind of checkpoints
they are maintaining what kind of
practices best practices or information
security hygiene they are maintaining so
these kind of things they are
advertising already but that needs to be
really looked into data privacy
this is gdpr
and this is the new thing which has gone
global data protection regulations so
that is something which really needs to
be taken care by all the cloud providers
and anyway this is an organization which
is affected in at the end data recovery
also I talked about that okay if you are
looking into the SLA how the data
recovery can be done or if you are
closing the term
in the term then
how you will get the data back
you
okay I'm coming to a different section
now I will hold and have a look if there
are some questions coming in and
[Music]
see some other questions
server less different from any
cloud-based service okay this I think I
will be addressing anyway in few sites
later which certification is better okay
this is also but anyway let me take that
in carrier growth Salesforce platform
developer or Service Cloud consultant
primarily this depends on first how the
person is really looking at his own
carrier graph if they were looking
themselves as a software developer or
just a cloud just a consultant and based
on my experience normally a functional
consultant are getting a higher pay up
so this is in terms of pay if I would
say certification is better but from the
satisfaction point of view it really
depends on the person how they want to
really go for it
okay
we're interesting one how can a normal
business transition to the cloud
successfully this is a kind of faced
decision you need to take if you are a
startup or if you're starting company
this is quite easy you can straightaway
go for the cloud-based thing but if
you're a small company then also it's a
bit easy but if you are from small to
mid-sized company then you really need
to take up a faced approach and you need
to think what you want to host in the
cloud and what you want to really keep
with you as a kind of efficiency and
improvement or maybe which you think
that this you don't really want to share
anywhere else so
primarily it is the customer facing
things which you normally look at
putting in first on the cloud part and
on the public cloud really
so when you say transition to the cloud
so I'm assuming that you are saying
transition to the public cloud and
that's what I'm trying to put in it
could be a private cloud as well you can
create your own private cloud and
depending on how much you are willing to
spend you can do a hybrid of that as
well okay now coming back to the slides
of
deserve roll hmm now there can be
different ways where you can have job
roles I'm primarily focusing only on the
cloud however there can be much more job
roles which are created just because of
the cloud storage and other kind of
services allied services which are
coming because of the cloud part so
there can be technology-based roles and
there can be product or company based
also technology base can be then you are
especially focusing on specific
technologies and going for that like
container as a service function as a
service or cloud itself as overall you
are doing that and product and company
based is like you're especially
targeting towards a product from the
company for example as your container
services so now you are going for issue
container services especially for that
or for that matter maybe docker
which is there so you are completely
going for taco and doing it so this is
in general how it can be and when we
look at the rows primarily there can be
very broadly three kind of things when
it's cloud architect which is like a
solution architect and this is the
person who is really looking at the
strategy of the enterprise from the
cloud computing perspective how to plan
what to get in cloud how to get a
structure delivery models and this will
in all the design implementation
defining the service levels how to
migrate the components from one solution
to the other solution so all these kind
of things cloud architect will be
looking at cloud engineer is primarily
on the implementation and management of
this delivery model so it can be any of
these delivery models and cloud engineer
is looking at that and normally
sometimes it is also referred to as
operations engineers or systems engineer
then there is software developer so they
are really there as a developer with
back-end front-end all kind of web
application development data and
application incubation this this is
there but the focus is primarily on
towards a specific cloud solution and
not on on in general for the software so
this is on the job role I'll just share
a bit of data so if you see 121 percent
growth rate in job posting between these
four years that included the term cloud
computing so you see that the kind of
growth it is there in terms of cloud
computing which is now gaining really
momentum on a very high level and
different kind of skills looked for in a
cloud engineer so I think this will
giving you a perspective already which
product is really being looked into
by the providers for cloud engineers and
that will really give some of the
questions answered already so like
somebody is asking should I go for a
sewer or GCP so you can have a look at
this thing and really look at which is
there and then them from the market
perspective and the employers
perspective and then you can decide
yourself
you
now the two days back I just saw in the
New Times of India itself the companies
facing talent crunch in cloud data and
if you see if you closely look cloud
architect is the first name which is
mentioned there and this is a really
skill which is looked after right now so
cloud architect and this is coming in
even before data scientists the storage
systems and management specialists and
blah blah blah so this is this is
something which is really really being
missed by the industry and they are
really looking for so for example in
this article only it was mentioned that
for every 10 requirements there are only
2 available cloud architects so this is
the kind of gap which is existing so the
persons who are really looking at maybe
cloud engineer they can also look for
cloud architects
you
okay now
coming to some of the future trends for
the cloud computing and that would be
really interesting looking at the time I
will try to be faster um so delight in
in one of the reports said by 2020 what
will cloud computing be drawing
driving - there will be a market worth
of dollar - 41 billion and that just to
give an idea this is twice the amount of
China I spent on arms in 2011 so the
services CIO system comm and this will
help cut data center energy usage by 38%
which is very good because then we are
going towards more greener part of it
and will host 15% of data availability
this is what 15% I mentioned when I was
talking about Cisco figures and in my
previous slide one of the slide and then
cloud computing is also enabling
mobility so if your data is not bound to
a data center or our piece of hardware
in some location then you are really
mobile and you can really access the
data from anywhere else anywhere on your
device analytics so huge amount of data
collection which the companies which are
doing over the marketing or maybe like
search engines so this is the Twitter's
and all these Facebook's all thats kind
of analytics is possible because of the
cloud data collection mass collaboration
again so like I gave an early example
how different companies can collaborate
at a level where they can just start
with a cloud and they can get the data
exchange and a very good example is
Skype for business you can immediately
get into video and Val connections even
WebEx for example is a good one which we
are using right now to connect and
we are really enjoying that platform
collaboration then huge data set
available so if you really want to see
some trends some kind of things which
are there so you have data available on
the cloud which you can really analyze
and get the some kind of trend or
problem solving things done out of that
data
cloud-based identity services so this is
something which is there and we have
been utilizing these without realizing
like if you open your phone and your
phone says authorized connections using
Facebook using Google ID so this is
already cloud-based identity service one
of the service provider is certifying
your ID to the other service provider
that okay yes this is a known user so
this is kind of cloud-based identity
service which is already available and
there is also at a
higher level it is certificate based
authentication also possible using
public key infrastructure so you can
have a soft PK ID for yourself generated
and then this can be used to
authenticate you so this is like
organizations like BD third they are
providing this kind of services which is
and there are consortium which are
allowing different organizations who are
member of that consortium to authorize
to each other so this is turning towards
completely collaborative model next I'll
jump to the creating specific building
blocks so single function so this is the
future architecture which is coming up
which is in the development service
oriented architecture container based
services so single function meaning they
are function is the smallest unit which
is available to the user based on the
triggers or alerts and this is
completely provided by the cloud
provider this helps some kind of batch
processing so you can really define an
alerts and triggers and a chain of
workflows to get into kind of server
less computing and I think somebody
asked me about server less computing so
this is where we are going into and so
less is
they'll have everything provided from
the cloud provider to you and you just
need to define the alerts and triggers
to really get into the services and even
this can be used for IOT internet also
things services or internet everything
ioe and this is charged for execution
time so you really saving it's only the
execution time so example the trigger
happens it is executed and this is
measured and charges based on that
execution time
then
service is closely linked to the
function because you can have a relay or
workflow of functions made which can be
a kind of complete service itself and
they are independently working with each
other you can define multiple micro
services using that
so you can have a container services as
an example and these are the complete
environment so this is a bit higher a
bit above virtual machines and giving
you even the OS and application level
segregation so that you have the full
container and then you can define your
own application on top and run on it so
there is machine learning this is kind
of my favorite because this is giving
open platform as a service like mine
sphere for myself from Siemens which is
there as a platform a cloud platform for
IOT and like IOT is predicted to be 50
point 1 million devices by 2020 so this
is important or really critical to have
a kind of operating system which is kind
of a below I'd the connectivity and the
platform based services to
such kind of trend and this can then
help even for the fleet managers for
different kind of factory based
automations and all kind of things which
you can imagine in kind of manufacturing
or ribbon mobility scenarios
so this gives an example a kind of
movement how things have moved from 2000
to 2015 and this is going further and
you see data centers infrastructure as a
service platform as a service containers
and then the server list so which is
function as a service
okay this gives you a kind of
comparative idea how things are
different in case of different models so
infrastructure-as-a-service you see all
these are there and from the previous
model there is a layer above addict as
function on all four and you also see
the containers also added here which is
put as optional and it can be used or
or they can be used or they cannot be so
this is already could be possible it
also gives you an idea what is user
management possible what can be scaled
and what is provider management so you
see function as a service
everything is provider management the
scalability on the function is with the
users so you can only work on the
function side you only focus on what is
your critical thing from the business
perspective you want to get done
this gives an idea about continent
versus virtualization so like I was
mentioning how it is different so this
is giving an idea that virtual machine
is having its own virtual OS and app and
wins laughs ladies everything like that
but here you can have a defined
container and in that OS you can have
one app to work - yeah and similarly on
the different container you can have
maybe us two or maybe similarly us one
and this is an engine which is running
on top
is machine learning I've just added two
slides for machine learning and AI just
giving an interface how things are
working so machine learning in general
is an input of data and then you have
them based on relationship different
patterns dependencies and go rhythms the
kind of output which is coming out and
how cloud is helping because if you see
the function part so function is
completely working or giving you this
kind of structure where everything is
provided from the cloud provider and you
adjust into identifying the patterns and
getting an output out of that
this is the data science the artificial
intelligence how they are linked so what
cloud is really able to give here is the
support for the big data you can have
really big data stored on the cloud and
based on different kind of new models
which are coming by containers or
function is a service or even micro
service you can define things on this
big data and you can work on getting
data mining or maybe deep learning or
natural language processing so you can
really get deeper into that
and cook okay I think come to the end we
have one minute just one net not let me
quickly take lovey what do you say we
can take a question yeah I thought I
have some questions so basically one of
a learner who is from whose name is
Dominic Johnson he is attending this
thing from YouTube and he does that that
he was thinking of learning epics but
don't know any language and that's how
cloud computing and how you can you know
this is how can you help them down to
understand that is it how can i he's go
from - should he go from 4 up XR cloud
and how about interrelated um that's a
good question I'm just kind of thinking
because this is more or less Salesforce
kind of interface which you can get with
FX and if you're really looking for a
development carrier then FX could be a
good choice because then you can really
work on a kind of Salesforce
infrastructure or maybe development on
Salesforce on top of that so and you can
be part of the community this is
interesting because Salesforce has been
the premier on web-based applications
and I would suggest that you can really
look into that for an app X kind of
thing but I'm not sure what he means
exactly by the language because FX
itself is a developer platform
completely so yes I don't even know even
though that would be you know that is
basically a Forsman choice on which is
at the two different directions so it's
a pretty low
so for a personal choice on interest as
well that's what I believe you yeah
exactly this is what I also earlier
mentioned that how the person looks at
his own or her own carrier choice they
can look in that direction this is
correct yeah we have one more question
from from a person whose name is Robbie
it's my name is well yeah right it is
can a non-technical guy start cloud
computing and cope up with the current
technology or what are the basic steps
of is acknowledged that he should have
very interesting question Ravi and this
non-technical guy I think at a very
abstract level the person can go into a
kind of infrastructure set of itself to
really get himself or herself acquainted
with what is basic at the cloud
computing and I would not discourage but
even today I have to learn a lot this is
something which is quite evolving every
day and we really need to learn every
day so I would say if you have a
learner's question with you then there
is no data for going into cloud
computing or a maybe for that matter any
technological ot matter and that goes
for learning which unit that's it yeah
even from the non-technical one more
question comes into my mind you know
while for a person who is who's a
business man and he has a group of
people technical people right so how can
a business can transition into something
a very highly profesh profitable
business with the help of cloud can you
just put some light on that as well I
think he really need to the businessman
really need to focus on the areas where
his course are going being worked for
different CFO's and business persons
I know that you need to really focus on
first identifying where the costs are
and then based on those aspects you can
really work or he can ask his team to
work on
kind of optimizing those costs or maybe
changing the model of that platform
completely so I giving an example maybe
for example if you are using say some
kind of homegrown software they are
using and they are spending a lot on
development and maintenance of that
software that would for sure show as a
big kind of cost already in that and
that he can really save by changing that
to the cloud model and going for a
provider who is providing that service
on paper use model so then it can be in
there in the beginning it can be a bit
difficult it will look a bit difficult
but as soon as three or four months or
some usual period passes then they will
start realizing the benefits both in
terms of many all the cloud benefits and
as well as the costing part yeah that
actually you know helps the startups as
well to you know manage that how much
they have the budget to invest in cloud
computing and and with the with also
keeping in mind provided that they have
a good strength of technical people who
can do it at a lower cost and in an easy
way as well that's the best battery with
the cloud computing because you don't
need upfront investment on that you can
really talk to the provider and say I
want to start this much in the beginning
and then you can negotiate on top how
you want to grow the things that so yeah
that's the best part
mm-hmm yeah and yeah okay now I've got a
question that is favorite or likely to
be everyone's favorite that what is the
highest growth in terms of salaries when
it comes to cloud computing yeah this is
uh nobody salary is enough but very
frankly I am NOT don't have already
often data for the salary change of
legally but what I have is that the
cloud architects they're really sought
after at the moment and the companies
are willing to pay them what they want
right and that that gives an idea what
what you can really look towards - yeah
and we all know that not every knowledge
never go waste now a knowledge will
always help you so clock even if you
know cloud computing and you don't know
anything else it will it is a add-on if
you know anything else and some some you
have basic technical knowledge and you
also know cloud computing that sin
another feather India in your hack right
yeah yeah yeah so I guess that's all the
questions I don't have much questions
over here from the lunar so thank you so
much sue did it was a great session and
yes we did learn a lot and we do get I
hope Ravi Brahma Viper and Dominic I
hope you have called you your questions
were really nicely answered and this
will help you and you know growing your
career in cloud computing so you know as
a last note final note I would really
like to thank sujeet for coming up and
giving the best knowledge in the market
for cloud and how can we grow our
knowledge in count covering and also
business in cloud computing so thank you
so much sujeet it was a quick session
Thank You Ravi thank you it's an Oran
it's a pleasure thank you India